vous démarrez vous théâtre cinéma direct
Alain Delon tranquille le toubib et vous
signez un contrat trois films dont vous
êtes parti tout jeune pour trois films
avec Alain Delon le
toubibé de carrière on est là et le
toubib marche pas de l'eau on fait un
peu sa tête de con finalement le contrat
s'allume ça s'arrête là vous vous êtes
une jeune femme en cas de confiance en
vous c'est pas trop quoi faire la télé
vous appelle en 81 et vous propose cette
série pause café postendresse vous
devenez Joël Mazar qui est une
assistante sociale et là c'est le carton
absolu ça dure énorme ça dure 2 ans
c'est combien de millions de
téléspectateurs je sais pas il y avait
des énormes 50% d'audience à cette
époque il y avait 45% d'eau
et le 3
trop mignonne mais trop mignonne
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je regardais ça
voilà
c'était une série positive c'est ça
qu'on aimait
très poli
arrêtez moi si je me trompe
c'est bon bébé c'est un générique
arrêtez moi si je me trompe on a
l'impression que vous avez toujours eu
un petit peu ce syndrome de l'imposture
c'est dire c'est vous allez là où vous
demande c'est que là vous faites deux
ans de ça puis vous vous dites quand
même le cinéma 3 ans de ça le cinéma
c'était bien un peu comme Columbo je
veux retourner aussi au cinéma donc vous
arrêtez la série vous repartez au cinéma
où vous jouez avec
Gérard Lanvin avec Thierry Lhermitte
vous repartez dans le cinéma quand même
oui mais en fait je repars en fait tout
ça c'est des
occasions qu'on a ou qu'on a pas
j'allais pas refuser de tourner avec
Gérard Lanvin c'était un super film en
plus pourquoi les producteurs me dit-on
comment ça vous dire un peu un peu le
syndrome Johnny Hallyday quand il essaie
de faire des films pardon tu es trop
marqué Joël Mazar les gens arrivent pas
à te voir dans un rôle c'est vrai
en fait c'est pas vraiment ça c'est que
c'est vrai que pause café ça a marqué
tellement les gens les gens m'appelaient
pause café quand ils me quand il voyait
bonjour el Mazar mais surtout plutôt
parce qu'a fait
mais en même temps c'est que j'avais
l'étiquette l'étiquette sociale
l'étiquette gentille à l'écoute mais
finalement finalement en fait quand
c'est moi qui écrivais les sujets
j'avais vers ça d'ailleurs
par exemple dans le Quitterie c'était ça
parce que en fait j'aime être à l'écoute
j'aime j'aime beaucoup les personnages
de ce qui commence ils comprennent pas
ils sont contre et puis petit à petit
comprennent des choses et ils changent
j'aime bien quand il y a une évolution
forcément vous enfoncez un petit peu
dans le cul avec Serge le roi pas le
début non puis Serge a été malade à
cette époque là et malheureusement il
était il était pas au mieux de sa forme
mais juste une petite rectification
parce que c'est Serge le roi qui est
venu me chercher pour faire pause café
parce qu'il avait tourné avec de long un
film qui s'appelle les enfants regarde
donc il le connaissait bien et il lui
faisait pas peur parce que Alain faisait
peur a beaucoup de monde il savait que
j'étais sous contrat avec lui en fait
c'est toujours tout ça c'était la peur
de Delon et on n'est pas me chercher
parce qu'il fallait passer par de long
et lui lui alors il avait peur de rien
de toute façon il a demandé Alain Delon
pas du tout tout le monde l'a cru mais
non il est beau vous êtes belle
du coup voilà et là à ce moment-là vous
rebrouillez un peu les pistes on a
l'impression que vous vous dites bon et
je vais plus être Joël Mazar le cinéma
ça marche pas forcément comme il faut
alors qu'on part dans la musique
et là vous faites deux trois singles qui
cartonnent c'est vrai touche un petit
peu à tout oui j'ai cette chance là
c'est quand j'ai lu votre bio je me suis
dit cette femme a fait plein de choses
des Monologues du vagin et tout ça du
théâtre et en vrai c'est vrai que
bêtement pardon avant de lire votre bio
vous étiez Véronique Jannot de pause
café post tendresse pour que ça c'était
là ben oui mais j'ai fait plein d'autres
choses mais mais en fait quand vous
dites alors vous décidez de faire si
vous décidez de faire là en fait moi je
décide rien
c'était ce rôle de pause café pardon
vous refusez d'avoir accepté sur vous
regrettez pardon ah pas du tout ce qu'il
aurait pu vous aviez le cinéma une
seconde ah non non non je pense que
quelque part je pense que quand ça fait
partie des grandes lignes quand il y a
quelque chose comme ça qui arrive dans
une vie ça fait partie des grandes
lignes et ça m'a énormément apporté ça a
été le ce qui m'a fait vraiment rentrer
dans dans le coeur des gens faire partie
de la de la vie de millions de Français
et j'ai rencontré des des
pleins d'acteurs en plus DM qui
débutaient avec le hitch Cornillac ma
jumelle il y avait j'ai rencontré des
gens formidables excusez-moi je vous
parle c'est parce que je cherche
totalement mes fiches sur je tire
totalement mes fiches c'est Monsieur que
j'adore oui Romeo bien sûr mais j'ai pas
les voilà voilà et voilà voilà
personne n'est viré
et après on reviendra sur vous parce que
quand même je sens que vous êtes une
femme fragile que vous n'osez pas dire
non il y a un petit sentiment d'un peu
sûr et même je le vois avec les hommes
et je vous en parle dans un instant
c'est un beau teaser Romeo alors vous
vous Romeo
pantin Claude Berry la vie est un œuf
tranquille et en 92 on vous appelle pour
faire une famille formidable énorme
carton évidemment vous jouez à côté de
Danny Duperey vous jouez Nicolas ça
marche bien mais c'est vrai comme vous
n'êtes pas encore très connu et tout ça
bon ça marche bien ni du Perret la star
et après c'est en 96 que la vie bascule
totalement puisque là vous allez partir
de 96 à 2008 vous allez jouer différents
rôles mais dans le sous le soleil ça
cartonne sous les samedis je sais pas
comment c'est ces trois quatre millions
de personnes ou véritablement vous êtes
le beau gosse vous êtes musclé vous avez
22 ans d'abord comment vous vivez ça
c'est-à-dire qu'au début c'est quoi
c'est les portes les soirées les boîtes
de nuit à Saint-Tropez dans les Porsche
franchement je m'en foutais un peu
c'était surtout quand même pas j'avais
déjà à l'époque une bonne équipe de
d'amis et ça tourne autour de ça j'ai
gardé mon équipe et on a on a continué
notre vie normalement peut-être que les
portes des boîtes de nuit s'ouvraient un
peu plus facilement mais à part ça il y
a pas vraiment eu de grosse différence
si je vous dis que quand la production
en plus attends j'ai bien vu qu'il y
avait il y a quand même oui le matos
j'ai drôle recharge les batteries
non mais ce qui est très important c'est
je vais vous dire quand la police m'a
appelé elle m'a dit on aura Véronique
Jannot je me suis évanoui
je suis chez mes larmes et Mehdi après
on aura romain sympathie et je te rends
je vous promets qu'au début j'ai dit
c'est qui et il m'a dit il m'a dit le
personnage est tombé votre nom de
Louis Lacroix de sous le soleil j'ai dit
[__]
et je pense que beaucoup de gens ont ma
réaction vous êtes Louis Lacroix de sous
le soleil et j'en avais oublié votre
prénom est-ce que c'est quelque chose de
fréquent est-ce que ça vous vexe parce
que c'est un peu comme si vous portez la
tenue de Casimir en fait vous êtes une
star mais derrière quelqu'un
ou la croix c'est pas quasiment c'était
une image cela dit je croisais quasiment
lors d'une
j'étais super touché de le voir quasimir
c'était c'était le personnage qui m'a
touché quand j'étais gamin si j'ai fait
le même effet au gamin des années 90
tant mieux oui mais vous me dites ça
mais là où je vous trouve un petit peu
tous les deux un chouïa hypocrite pas
vous verrouille
et toi tu es costaud alors vous n'êtes
pas hypocrite mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que après ça vous partez dans de
la musique et dans du rap comme si tout
d'un coup ou les cassé un peu l'image
montrer comme vous la musique arrêtez de
m'appeler Nicolas nana je suis Romeo
comme si vous voulez montrer autre chose
c'est vrai franchement c'est vrai je me
trompe
je t'ai entendu dire ce mot déjà
c'est faux aussi
je vous trouve un peu tous les deux
fontaines [__] on va encore inviter
des gens Laurent Laurent va encore
s'excuser
alors je m'excuse c'était pour rire
alors
de quoi
vous dites les producteurs nous crée un
rôle et nous ensuite nous plantent un
couteau dans le dos par derrière on peut
plus rien faire ça c'est votre phrase
d'accord
ça c'est moi ça ou c'est vous non c'est
possible
lorsqu'on vous a demandé pourquoi est-ce
que vous souhaitiez pas participer à des
programmes par exemple des dalles des
trucs comme ça vous aviez dit que vous
avez refusé splash à l'époque et
l'émission qui avait sur TF1 avec eux
voir là et que vous aviez un peu vous
êtes senti un peu utilisé par certains
producteurs et du coup vous refusez tout
ce genre de trucs maintenant c'est ça à
l'époque ça c'est ça c'est autre chose
mais non c'est pas ça non non je vais je
vais te répondre Danse avec les stars
splatch la Ferme Célébrité on m'a
proposé toutes sortes d'émissions à une
époque j'avais pas du tout envie de les
faire je me considérais comme acteur et
je pensais que j'avais vraiment rien à
faire dans ces émissions là faut que tu
saches que dès le départ dès le premier
tour
dès les premiers cours de théâtre à part
si si ça gêne pas du tout non je
regardais l'émission tu sais dans la
loge et je vous trouve assez détendu
tous là il y a que des gens qui s'aiment
hein
ça fait deux fois que je fais une bonne
qui passe pas si demain je suis dans la
Seine je ne suis pas suicidé
je veux le dire j'avais pas envie de les
faire j'ai trouvé pas à ma place je
trouvais ces émissions un peu
casse-gueule quoi à l'époque ils avaient
appelé mon agent notamment pour la Ferme
Célébrité la réaction spontanée qu'elle
avait elle leur a dit vous allez pas
mettre un lion en cage et ils ont
répondu bah si justement ça peut être
marrant moi j'ai compris qu'il y avait
un peu de sexuel juste au collier ils
aiment les micro d'accord merci mon cœur
c'est souvent pour les acteurs enfin en
fin de carrière qu'on propose
la question s'il te plaît je vais
revenir à Véronique ma question c'est
plus exactement c'est
Jérôme keruroser pardon qui est dans le
plus belle la vie comment Laurent pardon
je commence bien dit on m'a on a utilisé
utiliser pendant 10 ans en plus belle la
vie et maintenant je peux plus rien
faire voilà on m'a donné un rôle je peux
plus rien faire alors il y a peut-être
fallu que Peter Falk Peter Falk aussi
est-ce qu'il faut prendre ou pas est-ce
que c'est ça c'est une bonne question
personnellement je m'en plains pas
c'est simple en fait c'est c'est ma
façon de voir les choses je préfère dire
merci pour ce que j'ai plutôt que de
pleurnicher pour ce que j'ai pas ou ce
que j'ai pu je trouve que c'est une
grande chance qu'on m'a donné de jouer
d'abord dans la famille formidable
auprès de ses acteurs qui sont
merveilleux j'ai passé 26 ans auprès
d'eux c'était magique vraiment parce
qu'on partait loin on est parti à la
fois au Maroc en Thaïlande et tous les
ans partout au Portugal pas pour les
pays c'est le truc de se retrouver en
équipe dans des tu vois dans dans des
jolis environnements sur un tournage et
cette merveilleux donc et comment
veux-tu que je regrette ça et Véronique
est-ce que il y a il y a des rôles qu'on
vous a refusé ou que vous auriez aimé
faire mais vous avez pas pu à cause de
Joël Mazar on va dire
sur des choses et je l'ai pas su au
chocolat au chocolat
je pense qu'elle a fait plein de choses
parce qu'elle était aussi Joël Mazar
bien sûr bien sûr le problème c'est que
d'une chose c'est vrai qu'il y a des
acteurs je pensais à ça par exemple
Lanvin fusée Camping 2 très bien payé
qui nourrissent à repayer speed 2 a
refusé speed 2 DiCaprio dit je ne fais
qu'un film je ne fais jamais deux fois
le même eux disent si tu veux une
carrière de te lance jamais dans quelque
chose qui va être fonction comment on
dit fictionnelle est-ce qu'ils ont
raison moi je sais que j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi pour faire la troisième saison
de de pause café qui était pause café
post tendresse
j'ai pas regretté parce que ça m'a
permis de retrouver Serge Leroy et puis
de voilà d'être avec Bernard Lecoq que
j'adore qui est vraiment quelqu'un que
j'aime tendrement mais
peut-être que c'était un trou et en même
temps je sais pas non je pense et
peut-être pas mais vous avez en fait
tellement peu confiance en vous quand
j'écoutais des interviews de vous chez
moi jusqu'à 3h du matin non mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai j'écoute au contraire
c'est tout change j'écoutais une femme
qui était toujours un peu surprise qu'on
revient la chercher et tout ça et même
sur les hommes je peux le dire vous
m'aidez que je pouvais le dire je sais
pas alors un vous êtes magnifique de
vous êtes célibataire
et vous m'avez dit j'adorerais poser la
tête sur l'épaule d'un homme mais je
sais que le jour où je le ferai il
partira c'est quoi cette vision de
rester on sait jamais la solidité d'une
épaule est encore la patate c'est quand
vous êtes toujours un peu craintive je
préfère je préfère ne pas tester en fait
cette solide parce que ça veut dire que
on est en train de se casser la figure
moralement
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a quelque
chose que vous aimeriez vraiment faire
aujourd'hui est-ce que ce serait une
série est-ce que ce serait du cinéma
est-ce que vous êtes heureux est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que je suis heureux
oui est-ce que si TF1 vous proposer
demain c'est arrivé
demain nous appartient pardon demain
nous appartient et tout ça vous
accepteriez pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
oui et vous Véronique
en revanche
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il nous reste 30 secondes je
vous jure 30 secondes
si tu me le fais je te jure j'ai un pic
d’audience allez vas-y ouais vas-y ouais
mon premier c'est
mon deuxième
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'album elle chante toujours aussi bien
moi mon épaule elle partirait pas si tu
étais dessus je peux vous le dire rêve
Véronique Jannot vous avez tout pour
vous j'espère que vous en avez
conscience c'est en vente sur votre site
sur mon site parce que c'est une
autoproduction mais c'est assez indice
aussi pour petit et grands enfants parce
que je découvre un peu le monde de
l'enfant c'est
il a quelque chose de particulier c'est
qu'en fait il est de son temps dans le
sens où aujourd'hui il y a plein de gens
qui ont pas de lecteur CD et il a il y a
il est il est vendu avec un accoupon et
on peut
c'est pas grave merci beaucoup Roméo
d'abord été avec nous